majorité c'est les sans-papiers qui
travaillent même si tu ne crois pas on
peut faire des chantiers ici les gens
vont refuser de parler il y a beaucoup
l'homme qu'ils ont les douleurs dans
leur cœur
mais il peut pas parler moi je vais
partager parce que
il y a beaucoup de groupes comme ça
qui souffrent c'est pour ça que je vais
pas me cacher des
ici c'est ma chambre
c'est un désordre
difficile mais quand même c'est un peu
mieux qu'avant avant le domaine dans un
local à Aubervilliers je dormais s'il y
a un carton
[Musique]
dans mon pays si j'ai perdu mon emploi
je pourrais avoir un autre mais
tellement découragé j'étais obligé de
sortir chez moi pour aller chercher
ailleurs j'ai passé par Mali après
en Italie et en France maintenant
quand tu es là-bas
tu travailles sans payer un jour ils ont
attrapé quelqu'un devant moi qu'il a
refusé de travailler
ils ont tiré balle sur lui en fonction
de ça j'ai vu que ça devient plus grave
[Musique]
à peu près 30 personnes qui travaillent
dans la boîte mais à peu près deux
personnes seulement qui a le document
sinon tout le reste on est sans papier
[Musique]
le salaire de quand les élections du
travail
[Musique]
90 kg c'est ce qui a passé mon dos
et quand tu étais blessé était du monde
il te dit de ne pas dire que tu peux
placer sur le lieu du travail et quand
tu vas te faire soigner tu te Soignes
par tes propres frères
la dernière
[Musique]
on travaille plus on a plus de droit on
a travaillé des bâtiments difficiles
imagine-toi travail de 2 ans n'a plus
rien tout annuler donc je reprends à
zéro elle est des nouvelles lois
peut-être ceux qui ont la sérénité
même si ça les patrons quand le médecin
il a entendu ça là
on va pouvoir maintenant réclamer notre
droit donc on n'est pas compris c'est
réclamer les droits il va changer le nom
de la société maintenant il va
communiquer en quoi
la première chose c'est de pouvoir faire
constater là par le l'inspection du
travail de la réalité de l'ensemble des
situations totalement inacceptables
qu'ils vivent au sein de cette
entreprise ensuite on va un peu tracer
ces entreprises puisqu'on s'aperçoit
qu'on en a plusieurs et que avec des
gérants de pipe potentiellement des
entreprises qui s'ouvrent qui se ferment
là aussi c'est classique
et donc de regarder sous quelle forme on
peut intervenir déjà pour récupérer
l'ensemble des droits
et de trouver les solutions pour la
régularisation de ces salariés qui sont
là depuis plusieurs années en France
[Musique]